just uh been a lot of rumors connecting
you guys with antonio brown his
situation sort of i guess got clarified
last week with the suspension is that
anything you would still consider at all
or
well
what i'd say is just what we always say
because it's what we always do and who
we are john will is competing at every
turn and and there's never been a
process unless we just missed it that we
we weren't involved with to understand
what the chances were helping our club
and uh he's all over it he knows what's
going on right now and as much as you
can and
it remains that you know
it's a very complex situation and um
we just need to see where where it fits
somewhere down the road not you know and
that's that's all i got for you
pete carroll non-committal on potential
interest in antonio brown chris remember
last year
when the seahawks signed josh gordon the
story was it was going to be gordon or
antonio brown gordon was available not
for the rest of the season eventually he
was suspended again brown wasn't
available or at least if you signed him
he was technically available but they
may put him on the commissioner exempt
list now
we know brown is going to be out there
after eight weeks they're also
interested in josh gordon who may or may
not be reinstated before the start of
the season uh they've got dk metcalf
they've got tyler lockett russell wilson
was vocal earlier this year about
wanting some stars he got one in jamal
adams although he's not playing offense
you get antonio brown on that team i
mean
look we know antonio brown can be a pain
in the butt we know he's had issues off
the field that merit
punishment from the league and he's
getting it but man chris
if the guy can still play like he's
played most of his career
talk about boosting a team that may be
in need of a boost halfway through the
season yeah i mean
it's it's the ultimate balancing act of
risk reward it is i mean i i would think
again as antonio brown as good as he was
two three years ago no probably not but
i would still expect him to be like one
of the better receivers in football even
with the year off last year and all the
stuff that he's dealt with and even a
half a year this year we know he still
works out we've seen all that stuff but
man you know do you want to take the
risk you know i think we both agree
seattle's one of those teams that we
think can manage him and deal with it
but you know we know what can happen too
and do you want to upset a team that i
think you know you and i would agree is
in that super bowl conversation this
year they're there you know does he get
you over the hump and make you feel
better about it or does he get you there
and you go damn i think he's ruined the
dynamics of our offense here and we're a
little dysfunctional i think those are
all real questions they need to see
where he's at keep the communications
alive and make sure he's ready to play
football because it's not like they're
devastated they do have dk metcalf and
lock it like you mentioned who are
pretty damn good receivers
and keep your ears open as to who else
may be interested in him because you may
have to grab him before one of your
competitors
may do that i think the rams are a team
that should take a look at antonio brown
if and when he is available
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports